[موسيقى]
اكثر من نقطه على الخريطه العربيه تبلغ
مستويات قياسيه من الحراره منتصف اغسطس اب
2003 العراق يتصدر رغم اعتياد الطقس
العراقي على درجات حراره قياسيه في الصيف
لكن هيئه الارصاد توقعت الوصول لاثنتين
وخمسين درجه وقالت ان ثلاثه عشره محافظه
جاوزت نصف درجه الغليان فيما حذر الدفاع
المدني من وقوع حرائق في الاردن سجلت
الزرقاء 45 درجه وفق دائره الارصاد الجويه
تلتها العقبه بثلاث واربعين وعمان
الاثنتين واربعين ما ادى ببعض القطاعات
لتخفيض ساعه العمل وفي فلسطين سجلت مدينه
اريحا اثنتين واربعين درجه مئويه واعلنت
الارصاد الجويه الفلسطينيه تجاوز درجات
الحراره معدلاتها السنويه المعتاده بنحو
ست درجات مئويه اما في سوريا فوسط ظروف
انسانيه بالغه الصعوبه بمخيمات النازحين
شمال البلاد تواصل درجات الحراره ارتفاعها
متخطيه يوم الاثنين 45 درجه مئويه في
المغرب اعلنت المديريه العامه لهيئه
الارصاد الجويه ان الحراره تجاوزت معدلها
الشهري بثلاثه عشره درجه في بعض المناطق
يومي الجمعه والسبت الماضيين في مدينه
اغادير يوم الجمعه الماضي سجلت اكثر من 50
درجه مئويه وهي العليا على الاطلاق
بالمغرب متجاوزه حاجز الخمسين